[Music]
before we begin though there's one of
the things that we're experimenting with
next 18 this year and that's bringing
part of like our internal Google culture
to the conference so whenever we do
presentations at Google we have this
thing called a dory and the idea behind
the dory is if you know hey sometimes
you're sitting in a presentation and a
question pops up at the beginning of the
presentation and by the time you get to
the end of the presentation you're like
dory and the fish where you kind of
forget what your question was so we like
have people like just like you can put
your questions into a portal as you
think of them and then other people
using the portal can like vote the
questions up or vote them down so I'm
gonna try like if you're thinking of
questions as I'm presenting you know put
them into the Dory I'll answer some of
them at the end but I will make sure
that I answer every question if not
in-house today then I'll answer them
online so keep the link to the Dory
itself the instructions are here on how
to use it you use the app and you can
see the links that you're gonna follow
there and then you know you put your
questions into the Dory Q&A they
actually had a couple of questions
about an hour ago before the session
even began which I thought was really
cool and so thank you whoever it was
that asked those questions and I've
answered them already okay so we're
gonna talk about machine learning and
there's this ongoing revolution that's
happening in machine learning and
because of tensa phone because of how
we've open-sourced tensorflow the the
goal behind that is that you can be a
part of that revolution this isn't
something that we're just doing we've
open-sourced this platform we've worked
with lots of people we've worked with
lots of partners to build some really
interesting scenarios but any one of
these scenarios is something that you
can do and it's you're not gonna require
great expertise in machine learning or
AI or any of these things we're
democratizing it to make it easy for
everybody but a couple of my favorite
examples that I want to share so first
of all is I actually studied physics in
university and back when I was going to
university was when they discovered the
first extrasolar planets and how the
first extrasolar planets were discovered
where by some of the best
astrophysicists in the world and what
they were doing was that they were
taking a look at stars and some stars
very distant very large stars would have
a slight wobble in them and from time to
time they'd see the star
just do like a little wobble and they
try to figure out what was causing that
wobble and then they theorized the wife
there was a really big planet like a
Jupiter or Saturn orbiting close to that
star then what would happen is the
gravitational attraction of the large
masked planet could cause a wobble in
the star itself and as a result we
discovered the first extrasolar planets
but they were very large planets that
were very close to their parent stars
since then in the 20 odd years since
then we've discovered thousands and
thousands of planets and just in the
last year through machine learning and
through being able to machines being
able to spot patterns in the behavior of
stars not only are we discovering
extrasolar planets we're actually able
to see things like in the Kepler 90
system we're able to count the planets
that are in the star and the Kepler 90 I
this planet is a small rocky planet
which has got an orbital period of only
about 14 days so it's no longer limited
to large stars that are large planets
that are really close to their host star
we're actually being able to map these
solar systems and in the case of the
Kepler 90 system we've actually mapped
eight planets on what the size of those
planets are and then through the
spectrographic analysis actually being
able to identify some of the materials
and the makeup of these planets another
example is in something called diabetic
retinopathy and diabetic retinopathy is
a very common disease and it can cause
blindness and worse if it's not
discovered early and if it's discovered
early it's very cheap and it's very easy
to treat with drugs and some of the
machine learning research that we've
been working on has actually through
just simple pictures of the cornea being
able to spot some of the markers of
diabetic retinopathy so it can be
diagnosed early and it can be diagnosed
really cheaply and now we're lucky
enough most of us to live in places with
great hospitals like San Francisco I'm
from Seattle and that kind of thing
but there are parts of the world that
they don't have access to this kind of
imaging equipment and we think wouldn't
it be marvelous that if someday and
someday very soon just something cheap
like a cell phone there you will be able
to do the machine in Ference on a cell
phone to be able to take a photo of a
cornea loaded into a cell phone and do a
diagnosis right away things like this
we're learning are beginning to
revolutionize healthcare and we found
like someone
our results that while ophthalmologists
some of the most skillful
ophthalmologists in the world have like
a 99% hit rate in being able to diagnose
these things some machine learning
models that were that we've been
building are actually doing the same
they're equivalent and sometimes even
slightly better than a human
ophthalmologist now the idea here is not
to replace ophthalmologists the idea is
to enhance what they can do if an
ophthalmologist can see a hundred people
in a day instead of five people in a day
by using something like this everybody
benefits another one that I've been
really interested in I find fascinating
is in understanding and being able to
control the deforestation of our planet
and there have been some machine learned
projects have been built where what
they've done and I believe it was in the
Amazon rainforest that they used old
Android phones you know those ones that
you're probably going to throw away and
they've been building tensorflow machine
learn models that will spot the signs of
logging and spotting the signs of
logging can actually be very simple it's
the sound of a chainsaw it's the sound
of trees falling and by training a model
with those sounds by training a model
with those things and putting it onto a
cell phone having that cell phone be
connected and then spreading them
through the forest instead of having
people going and trying to monitor to
see where illegal logging is going on
these things once they detect that they
dial home and it's been cutting illegal
logging drastically another personal
favorite of mine and this one's a little
bit more fun is being able to use in the
Google arts app and this you can
download and play with the play on the
Play Store right now is only going to do
is you take a selfie and then what it
will do is based on the pattern of what
it sees in that selfie it will match
your face with famous works of art like
in this case you can see here this young
lady she is very distinctive eyes and
she's got a very nice little smile and
her eyes and smile get matched very very
nicely to paintings like this one and
this one and if you try it yourself it
can be a lot of fun this morning I
decided to sit down and try it out for
myself
and I got this
now to me the guy on the right looks
more like John Cleese and he looks like
me but I mean what can you do so but
then I thought maybe I can try to fool
the algorithm so I decided to put a cup
of coffee in front of my face and I got
this you know so I guess it thought the
beard and the cup of coffee looked very
similar so you can have a whole lot of
fun with this and again it's it uses
machine learning and it's been the
algorithm the model has been built used
using all of this famous artwork and
then what it does is like when I take a
selfie it matches my face it extracts
features from my face and it tries to
find artwork with similar features and
then it matches me accordingly but what
is machine learning you come to
conferences like this one you come to
maybe Google i/o you go to AI
conferences and you hear all these great
scenarios about finding planets and
curing diseases and matching faces with
John Cleese are junkies look-alikes but
what actually is machine learning so the
way I like to look at it is if you think
about how many of us here are coders by
the way how many programmers say oh good
most of us okay so classical programming
when we think about it is you think
about classical programming is a black
box and you put data and you put rules
into that black box and you get answers
out of it so if I were to think about
say if I'm building something that's
like a dog versus cats classifier that
would be really difficult right how do
you tell the difference win a dog in a
cat you know cats might have pointy ears
and they're planning to murder you dogs
probably have long floppy tongues and
they love you for the rest of your life
but those things are really hard to do
in rules right there those things are
hard to do in coding and most of us who
are classical programmers we've used
Java we've used c-sharp or C++ or any of
these things that's what we do we write
rules if this then that wild this do
that
all of those kind of things and then
those worlds operate on data we compile
them into something of value and that's
something of value gives us what we need
that gives us the answers out well all
machine learning is and the revolution
around machine learning is it flips the
axis on this diagram so machine learning
is you put the answers in you put the
data in and you get the rules out so it
may not seem like much but when you
start thinking about some of the
scenarios that now become possible I'm
wearing a watch a SmartWatch at the
moment which tracks my activity
Swach knows when I'm walking it knows
when I'm running it knows when I'm
swimming and my case probably where I'm
trying not to drown and you know it can
detect all of these things but think
about walking and running now if you're
a classical programmer how would you
tell the difference when somebody's
wearing a watch between walking and
running maybe it's based on their speed
you'd somehow be able to infer the speed
based on the location of the watch maybe
if the watch has a heart rate sensor
it'd be based on their heart rates but
some people when they're running
probably have a much lower heart rate
than I have when I'm walking and how do
you tell the difference between when I'm
walking and running that sometimes if
I'm going really fast I might be walking
downhill and sometimes if I'm really go
I'm going really slow I might be running
uphill so all these if then become very
very difficult to build something like
an activity tracker like I have on this
watch but with machine learning that
when you say okay I'm not gonna write if
ten rules I'm gonna give it all of the
answers I'm gonna say okay we're gonna
like when Apple created this watch and
when they've been doing it with the
recognition on this watch they've had
thousands of people exercising and say
okay right now I'm running right now I'm
walking right now I'm swimming and from
that they've been able to build models
and anybody who builds any kind of
activity activity recognition does the
same thing so now you're feeding into
this thing all the answers this is what
walking looks like this is what running
looks like this is what swimming looks
like and you feed it in the data this is
what it looks like and as a result when
you build a model around that then out
of that will come the rules so now in
future if you pass it a bunch of data it
will say I think you're walking I think
you're running I think you're swimming
and that's the whole revolution of
machine learning it's not a lot when you
think about it when you look at the two
diagrams they don't look very different
so what I always encourage people to do
is like think about the scenarios that
disempowers think about for example the
planet spotting that I spoke about
earlier on that would not be easy to do
with if-then rules it'll be possible but
it's a lot of code that you have to
write so that a code do you have to
maintain and then when you get new data
in that breaks the rules you probably
have to rewrite the rules think about
things like the diabetic retinopathy the
same thing so when we talk about
tensorflow and when we're building our
tensor flow we always ask people just
remember this diagram this is all about
you getting your data understanding your
data under getting the answers that's
called labeling the data and then having
a framework that will allow you to
manage them so
and build something that would give you
inference so that you give it future
data and then it will tell you what the
class of that data is so now there's a
whole bunch of products that we built at
Google and you've probably seen a bunch
of them this morning in the keynote and
I just wanted to highlight one here so
the idea behind these is that we've been
working on this stuff for years we've
been working on you know how to build
something that provides great inference
that provides for great machine learning
and on top of that we've built some
products so that if there's some
scenarios that you want to do like face
detection logo identification label
identification etc then there's a
product like cloud vision that does it
but these aren't different products
cloud vision is built on top of
tensorflow
so tensorflow is the framework that I've
mentioned if you're not familiar with it
it's open source it's free you can go
download it and you can play with it and
we define it as the machine learning
platform for everybody to solve real
problems so I just wanted to set the
level of where we're at for this session
before I start going into some of the
new stuff on what we've been working on
in the last year so here's where we've
been going in the last 12 months so
first of all the one thing one number
one piece of feedback that we've had
from software developers was like will
you please support my language I love
tensorflow I love machine learning I'm
not a Python Easter I really want to be
able to use things such as Swift or II
won't really want to be able to use
things such as JavaScript and as a
result these are two of the things that
we've been working hard to add to the
platform I'm gonna be showing some
JavaScript JavaScript stuff later and
I'm also doing a session immediately
after this one in Kara members upstairs
or downstairs upstairs in their 3000th
and I'll be showing some JavaScript
demos there so the idea is as a software
developer you know the JavaScript as a
skill is a highly sought after skill
it's a very common skill and we really
wanted to bring these scenarios of being
able to do machine learning to
JavaScript developers because then two
things can happen number one you can
actually execute models directly in the
browser and number two you can even
train models directly in the browser
there's a really cool demo if you go to
jsr tensorflow org where it's a pacman
game and if you've ever seen the Google
doodle of pac-man if you remember that
one you can actually train pac-man based
on the webcam so you can point out point
down point left point right and then you
can control pac-man that way all done
within the browser so there's no
round-tripping of code to Google or
anywhere else
all of the training is done in the
browser of the model you're passing it
in the answers by saying this is up
you're passing it in the data by frames
of your finger pointing up and then you
train the model I know and it takes a
few seconds it's really cool stuff but
this then opens up several different
scenarios for a machine learning and the
direction that we've been trying to take
with tensorflow is really threefold so
number one there's tensorflow itself so
there's the main framework of tensorflow
and this is designed to allow you to
train models and to execute models on a
variety of devices so what that provides
you is the api's and the SDKs and the
ability to take the data take the labels
or the answers into that data compile a
model and then in run inference on that
model in a variety of places serving
enough of web browser etc etc but in
addition to that this year we've been
focusing very hard and it's part of my
core passion is on something called
tensorflow lights and the idea behind
tensorflow light is that this is just
for executing models and running
inference and it allows you to do it on
a variety of devices so Android iOS
you've probably seen we've run some
demos on Raspberry Pi and we're working
on more IOT devices we'll have some
announcements about that shortly so the
idea here is that sometimes training a
model you need a big expensive
workstation you need maybe CPUs or GPUs
to train something but you want to be
able to distribute that model to people
to be able to use it anywhere like the
diabetic retinopathy I spoke about
earlier on wouldn't it be great if
places in the emerging worlds with a
cheap cell phone could just have a
simple app with a model running on that
app and then they pass a photograph of
the cornea of an eye into it and then it
were on inference on that and give you a
prediction about whether this person is
diabetic retinopathy or not that's the
idea behind sensor for low light to be
able to take these big models that you
build on workstations but take them out
of the big enterprises take them out of
the universities and give developers an
opportunity to build something that
thousands of people use millions of
people can use and to change the world
so that's our goal behind tensorflow
light now notice that's just the runtime
you're not gonna be doing any training
on the devices because they've got
relatively less power and then thirdly
is tensorflow dot j s so this is
JavaScript and as I mentioned earlier on
here's a case of now if you
to distribute training to people so you
know the nice thing about web technology
with a web browser you type in the URL
your application executes with in that
person's browser what if you have a
scenario where people want to give you
data or you want to train an a model off
of people's data and off of the labels
that they give you can now distribute
the gathering of this data over the web
either train it directly within their
browser of course have them send it back
to you where you can train it by it
working in JavaScript and another nice
part about being able to do this in
JavaScript is does anybody use a cloud
functions a few our cloud functions for
firebase okay so as you know they run in
nodejs and if it runs in nodejs now by
having JavaScript on there you can
actually execute a function to either
run inference on a machine lard model or
to build a machine learning model so
think about when you use the nice thing
about cloud functions is that they
operate off of triggers where a trigger
is something happening in your network
or something happening in your system
for example if your user logs into your
application that's a trigger and then in
so instead of you explicitly calling a
piece of code you could say this has
triggered this code to execute and you
then may have a scenario where okay a
user has logged in I want to run an
inference maybe C to do something like a
capture automatically behind the scenes
those kind of things this there's lots
of scenarios it's up to you to kind of
think of what would work best for you so
as I've mentioned one of my passions is
mobile and so I'd like to talk a little
bit about sensor flow light so this is
what it's like to use it so this is Java
code running on Android so if you're
caught lanista as well if you like
Kotlin of course this will work in
Kotlin if you're an iOS developer right
now it only works in C++ we haven't
built the projections into objective-c
or Swift yet for it so you'd have to
write C++ to do the inference but we're
working on that but all you have to do
is very simply is that there is a
package called org dot tensorflow dot
light dot interpreter and on this one
you would load your model so earlier I
spoke about building a model you give it
answers you give a data it gives you
rules you compile that model using
tensorflow that model from tensorflow
then to be able to run on mobile use the
process called flattening where the idea
is you take that and it flattens it and
make
more compact and it removes some of the
larger floating-point operations and
stuff like that makes it smaller so
we'll run on on a mobile device and the
file extension for that is TF Lite which
is why you see here new interpreter
awesome model dot TF light and then all
you have to do with that as you pass it
your inputs and it gives you back the
outputs so for example I don't know if
you're writing a classifier like I
mentioned for diabetic retinopathy your
input would be your image or how you've
processed that image so that the model
would recognize it and your outputs that
it would give you back would be a
probability of the this person having
that disease excuse me a performance of
tensorflow light is actually really nice
as you can see here we did this
benchmark and there's famous machine
learning models called mobile net and
Inception which I use for image
classification and when we flatten the
model when we ran it on tensorflow light
on an android device or an iOS device
and we did some benchmarking in q1 of
this year these are the the performance
increases that we've actually seen so
the orange bar is running it on
tensorflow and a traditional workstation
the gray bar is running it on tensorflow
light on a mobile and we can see that
inference is very very fast and I'm
going to show a demo in a moment of me
doing a live image classification and
you'll see how fast that it will
actually execute actually I'll do it
right now so if we can switch the demo
machine so I need to sign in sorry
okay so I'm actually going to run this
in the Android emulator
which I know is incredibly brave of me
live on stage so as you'll see it's
running so I'm running the Android
emulator here and you can see the webcam
and the Android emulator is going and
it's actually classifying three things
so what what's happening is this is
mobile net's has been trained with a
thousand different images so there's a
neural network that's been trained to
detect a thousand different types of
image and so what happens is now every
time it's capturing a frame from the
webcam it's or from the front cam on
there on the emulated phone and what
it's actually doing is its passing that
to this compiled model this compiled
model is coming back then with a set of
probabilities of each of these 1000 so
like right now I'm not showing it a
banana so it's setting it a probability
of like you know less than point zero
one one percent that it's a banana and
then I'm taking the top three of that it
actually gave me back and then
representing them so you know we have
this grid on the wall behind us
obviously it hasn't been trained for
that but that kind of looks like a
strainer and as a result is saying hey
that's a strainer and as you can see
then that above that that 1385
milliseconds that's the amount of time
it's taking to do the inference but
considered that that's actually running
on the emulator on my desktop as as I'm
speaking what did it say something funny
sometimes it says like - under something
when I step in front of it let's see I'm
an Italian Greyhound yeah hey I wish I
was that fast and but like if I if
you're familiar with Silicon Valley and
the hot dogs not hot dogs thing I don't
know how it work in this light so we'll
see but this is my famous banana demo
but let's see if it says it's a banana
there we go one one hundred percent
probability that was a banana I have to
put this behind I was cheating you know
so you know so that's like with the
mobile net models the famous model
amongst researchers they've taken a
thousand images we've built this neural
network that can then classify amongst
those thousand images strainer
shower-curtain and all those are three
of those images banana and Italian
Greyhounds or others and this is now
running on android as you can see here
it's it's doing pretty well it's only
taking like 1100 milliseconds to
actually identify something when running
on an emulator I also have this running
on my IVA pixel - phone ever running on
my phone if you see me later and you
want to see a demo of how fast it is on
actual hardware that it can do this
inference usually in 50 now 50
milliseconds or less so if we can switch
back to the desktop or to the slides
please I'm a keyboard I'm a sock I'm a
strainer I'm a running shoe yeah can we
switch back to the slides please before
I embarrass myself or other I'm a
hamster so the next one that I mentioned
so therefore the one of the remember
there were three run times was ten to
flow there's tenths of a lowlight and
then a sense flow J ass so tensorflow J
s the idea is that we've been working
hard we released this in March of this
year and we see the two main scenarios
for this is number one to be able to do
training or inference within the browser
it takes advantage of things such as
WebGL when it's running in the browser
so it can be very very fast and then on
the other side of it if you have servers
and you want to execute stuff on a
nodejs server feed that in something
like a cloud function or just your own
nodejs server then you can do so as well
and the really neat thing like I've
mentioned about this and I've know I'm
repeating myself but it is really cool
is the fact that you can do both
training and inference so you can
actually present somebody with a webpage
they give you data and it will train a
model based on their data and then they
can execute inference on that or you can
build a model such as the mobile net
model that I've mentioned which is the
one that I just used for the image
classification download so that browser
and then retrain the final layer of that
with classifications of their own and
that's how the pac-man demo works if you
go to JSTOR tensorflow org and take a
look at the pac-man demo that will be
trained with four new classes of image
one for up one for down and one for left
one for right you can do however you
like I tend to use my finger for
training it or you can some people will
actually look up look down look left
look right and while it's a fun little
demo think about the impact that that
could have on things such as
accessibility you know sometimes we
build accessibility into products but
the accessibility tends to be a common
solution for the the I don't want to use
the term lowest common denominator but
you know what I mean for the for the
mass denominator in this case but there
might be for an individual
the accessibility might work differently
maybe they want to scroll by going like
this maybe they want to scroll by going
like this I don't know or scroll by
nodding their head that you could
actually you know use an image
classifier in the browser retrained in
the browser for different classes like
say scroll or click or something like
that so that accessibility could be
customized to a particular user these
are the kind of scenarios that are now
becoming possible we can't build them
all we can't even think of them all you
know that's why you know we like to talk
about tensorflow with folks like you
that I know there are people in this
audience right now we've got fabulous
scenarios and they just haven't had the
tools at which to build them and we're
hoping that the tools that we're
building will unblock you from being
able to do that so coding so perhaps the
biggest changes in tensorflow as well as
adding this new stuff is in some of the
coding that we've been able to provide
so if you've been a tensorflow developer
up to now ads and you are a developer
rather than an academic if you've come
from a development background then it
the coding of tensorflow models might
have seemed a little alien to you the
idea was you define a model you end up
doing something called building a graph
and you build everything ahead of time
and then you execute the graph to do the
training you know as software developers
I don't know about you I'm I can't write
more than three lines of code without
having a bug in it and as a result I
like to write code two or three lines at
a time run them task them write the next
two or three lines run them test them
and that's traditional programming and I
didn't really work very well with
tensorflow
so we have something that we put into
tensorflow that which I'm gonna show
that actually I went to there I went to
the last one first we put something into
tensorflow that we call the eager
execution and the idea behind eager
execution is what that gives you is the
ability to be like a pure Python
programmer but continue to build
tensorflow models you get things such as
step-by-step debugging you get the
immediacy of being a real Python
developer and then also as you're
building your models if you're familiar
with things such as gradient descent and
there's differentiation in math that
needs to be done to determine loss and
all that kind of thing you don't lose
that weave there's something called a
gradient tape in there and based on the
name tape if you're from the VHS world
like I used to be you know the idea is
that's recording everything on tape and
that tape you can go back and forward
all that kind of stuff so it's like
you're not losing any of the value that
you had by when you had when you were
building graph based stuff by changing
to immediacy because things such as a
gradient taper there but let me skip
back so the other big change and to me
the other really exciting big changes
and how you build models so we've been
working really closely with Karis and
Francois Shuai a who invented care us
now works for Google and he works on our
team and so he has been bringing care us
to tensorflow in the TF doc ARS
namespace and if you've done any
construction of neural networks if
you've done anything like that and we
want to get into the really complicated
stuff
the idea behind care us is that it makes
it really easy now some of the terms
that you see on the slide here if you're
not a neural network person may seem
unintuitive to you and I'm really sorry
about that but the idea when you think
about it when you define a neural
network generally you're defining layers
of neurons and then in each layer of
neurons you're defining behaviors and in
those behaviors there's generally two
things that you define one is called an
activation function and this is what it
takes to actually activate that neuron
and how it behaves when it is activated
and the other one is called a loss
function and this is how am I going to
what type of function am I gonna use to
minimize loss in this layer if you're
not a neural network person sorry louder
that would be kind of gibberish to you
but the code to do this was actually
very complicated before chaos and would
care us here here's how I can now define
a neural network I'm defining it and
it's just like hey I'm creating a
sequential network so I have a number of
layers and they're operating in a
sequence here's my shape of my input 28
by 28 you know my first layer in my
network well this is what it's going to
be it's convolutional two-dimensional
one and I'm my activation in this is
something called a reloj and I'll
continue to fight to define my network
like that this kind of code to be able
to find a network like this it might
have taken dozens if not hundreds of
lines of code previously but what care
us as you can see it's if you're a
neural network person that's intuitive
to you if you are just learning this for
the first time a lot of these these
terms will seem very difficult to you
but it'll actually as you start learning
and as they start growing in it you'll
see that this is actually really
simplified it for you think about it in
terms of object-oriented development
you're creating an object which is your
sequential neural network and you're
setting properties on that
you're saying this layer looks like this
has this function this layer looks like
this has this function it's really as
simple as that
then this input processing the most
important thing when you're defining a
neural network is you got a feed a good
data if you remember my diagram earlier
on where I said you give it data and you
give it answers and it infers the rules
you got to give a good data
you know garbage in garbage out or if
you remember johnny-five need input so
it's like so being able to give a good
data you need to be able to have the
tools to define your data and to take
dirty data that you might have and clean
it or to have tools to take data that
you have and do things like normalizing
it or making it easier to understand for
neural network and then also more
importantly if you're building giant
neural networks that take a lot of
training as you're feeding data in you
want to be efficient if you feed in a
terabyte of data and then wait a hundred
hours for it to Train and then you've
another terabyte of data and you wait a
hundred hours for it to train that's not
very efficient so there's a concept
called data pipelines where you can
optimize your input of data to the time
that takes to train the data and we've
been building that out in something
called the TF data namespace so instead
of you just taking random data in a data
structure like numpy or lists in Swift
or something along those lines if you
actually take your data and you format
it with the TF data namespace it's
synchronized with the training and as a
result you can make your input of data
and training pipeline much more
efficient so eager I've mentioned
earlier on and so now the next thing is
we've been working really hard on these
things called cloud CPUs so T and TPU
stands for a tensor so the name
tensorflow
comes from the flow of tensors through
network and tensors are a way that you
can define your data so that they're
optimized for neural networks and for
neural networks to process them so we
said we wanted to build a chip that's
designed specifically for processing
tensors and that's why we came up with
this thing that we call the TPU the
tensor processing unit they are highly
highly highly optimized for tensor flow
and as a result you can see some of the
the data about this here
you know it's high bandwidth memory
there's 180 teraflops per device which
apparently is quite a lot but I'd rather
look at the results oh sorry before I go
to them I like to kind of use an analogy
for that
so think about when you're training a
neural network on your laptop or on your
desktop PC that probably has a CPU and a
CPU the idea behind that is that's a
chip that's designed for processing
anything right it's designed for
managing the windows on your screen it's
designed for your networking stack it's
designed for all of these things and
it's a little bit like a Swiss Army
knife
you know it's designed to be able to do
everything but it's not particularly
optimized for anything so as a result
it's not optimized for training and
machine learning and maybe you want to
build a model in that model might take
you a month to build on a CPU or it
might take a year depending on the
amount of data that you have
so the idea what the TPU is that it's a
highly optimized highly focused knife
it's like a sushi chef's knife so if
you've ever known a sushi chef tour if
you've ever sat in a bar where the
people are making sushi they have these
highly optimized highly sharp knives
that they can use to cut the fish
without like taking bones and all of
those kind of things with it and I
always like to say like you know people
go why would I want to use a TPU why
would I want to pay for TPU and think
about it in those terms if you need to
train a model and you've got a lot of
data to train that model on like the
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
hours it takes to do something like
activity recognition on a watch you want
that training to happen quickly and you
want it to be optimized for actually
training that model and so I always like
to say well if you're gonna use the CPU
you're using a Swiss Army knife to make
sushi which you don't really want to do
so taking one common model called ResNet
for image classification here's some of
the results that we got from using a TPU
on it
so a number the number of images per
second being fed in using TF data we're
about you know two thousand seven
hundred and synthetic images so the idea
was like you take in the real image we
do some processing on that to make a
synthetic image and then they were being
fed in it was over 3000 per second and
we found that we were able to Train it
to 76 percent accuracy so that is when
you do the classification like I was
doing earlier on it's right 76% at a
time on image net but doing this on a
tensor sorry on a on a TPU on a sense of
a tensor processing unit the cost for
doing this was actually about $85 when
we did this now compare that like if you
were to buy a GPU or many universities
were renting access to GPUs if the cost
was in the use
the tens of thousands of dollars brought
it down to the thousands of dollars
there was one experiment and when we
redesigned this slide actually for
presentation that Jeff Dean was giving
back in April and we put it with $85 on
there and before he went on stage
somebody did another test and they
actually had it significantly lower than
that I'm not allowed to say the number
but the point is it's actually going
down sharply you know so think about
building a really really complex model
you're talking about now can cost in the
tens of dollars instead of in the
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars and if you take a look at this
link you can actually see the benchmark
submission that we put in at Stanford so
some of the other things that we've been
trying to do is that you know as
tensorflow it's moving towards version
1.2 end very soon is that it's now time
to bring more developers into the fold
it's becoming less of an academic
infrastructure and academic framework
and we're trying to make it more and
more developer friendly so developers
can start building real things with it
things such as the cell phone that I
spoke about and scenarios with that one
and as a result we launched a blog on
blogger tensorflow org and we launched a
YouTube channel I personally run the
YouTube channel so if you've got any
ideas for videos or any questions you'll
see me all over that one and please you
know reach out and happy to create any
videos that for scenarios that you want
to see and you want to learn about also
what we've been trying to do is to
empower everybody to learn and explore
machine language machine learning
through something called the machine
learning crash course and it's this link
at the bottom here gioco slash machine
learning crash course is a place where
you can learn it and not trying to be
salesy about it or anything but this was
the course that we built to train us so
I learned machine learning is to work on
firebase at Google I learned machine
learning while I was on the firebase
team using the internal version of this
course so this is what we've used to
train the actual Google engineers who
are building the thing so some other
things that we've been working on
tensorflow hub is the next one so if you
think about models that there are common
scenarios for models like image
recognition or translation or tax
classification so we said we want to be
able to create a hub where people can
download those models and use them and
maybe even use parts of them in their
own models if you're familiar with
tensorflow a lot of the models that
we've done we've just put on github and
you know github is great
can download like a model off of that
and you can use it but it's not
optimized for something like this it's
not like a catalog it's not searchable
you know it's not you know easy for
everybody to share in one place so the
idea is that we wanted to build
tensorflow hub or TF hub as we call it
so that you can find models that you can
reuse you can find models that you can
build on or you can of course you can
share your own models and again it's at
that URL sense float org slash hub so
one of the really things that one of the
things that's kind of coming in the
future we're still working hard on it
that we're really passionate about now
is what we call learn to learn or auto
ml and the idea is we said okay well
what if today you want to build a
solution what do you need you need
machine learning expertise you need
people who understand Python or whatever
the language I was talking about earlier
whatever language is talking about
earlier can do you need them to be able
to understand the data how to format the
data put that into pipelines how to
design a neural network there's a lot of
expertise yeah of course you need all
the data and you also need the
computation power this is what the world
looks like today if you want to build a
good solution we said what if we could
take the deep ml expertise out of that
and just say data plus lots and lots and
lots of computation because machine
learning after all as you feed it in the
answers you feed it in the data's you
feed it indeed and it comes with up and
it comes up with an inference from it so
if you remember this slide that I showed
you earlier on I've been working on
tends to fail for about six months I
still don't understand how for the words
on this slide not many people do you
know I don't know why for example I
would use a back spooling of two two to
two instead of three three three three
other than a lot of experimentation a
lot of trial in a lot of error you know
there are people who can understand the
neural network and understand the math
behind a neural network and who maybe
write better code than I would here but
a lot of time when I'm building
something like this it's a lot of trial
and error it's a lot of okay where am I
going to flatten it where am I going to
do drop outs where am I going to do all
these kind of things and it's there's a
there's a bit of a black box element in
designing these neural networks that you
know you can take a look at there are
academic papers coming out on a daily
basis that say well if you want to do
image recognition you should do this
many drop out so you should do that many
drop out so you should use a rel uu or
you should use something else it's not
as prescriptive as well maybe many ways
it could be so
ask about say it's not as prescriptive
as writing typical code but then
sometimes well is it better to do a for
loop is it better to do a while loop or
you know these kind of things in typical
code and it's the same and it's the same
kind of thing that will happen when
you're designing neural networks should
I design it with this number of input
layers or this type of function so we
said well what if like you know this
kind of code instead of a human doing a
lot of trial and error behind that that
we actually have a computer do the trial
and error behind that then we say okay
we know roughly what our neural network
should look like and we know roughly
what kind of activation function should
be on there and what kind of dropouts
and all that kind of stuff and what if
we then say take that and then train on
that but then we tried lots of different
ones
you know we changed the function here we
change the design of an outer layer
there all these kind of things and we
iterate and iterate and iterate and then
we evaluate those models then we could
actually have a computer learning how to
learn we could actually build a machine
learning kind of thing that learns how
to learn now the computational expense
for this is really really big right now
which is probably why Google are the
only ones doing it but with Moore's law
being Moore's Law it's getting cheaper
over time and as a result there's you
know that we can actually start thinking
about in the future of building neural
architectures that optimize themselves
so some of the things some of the
results that we've had out of this is
that when we take a look at some of the
handcrafted models that are out there
that have been built by some of the
world's greatest researchers you know if
you take a look at the x axis here the x
axis here is the number of operations of
computation that are needed to see that
as the expense ultimately even though
that expense is coming down over time
and the y axis is the accuracy and
precision of these image recognition
models so if we take a look at something
like Inception which you can see in the
lower left that's a very cheap and very
easy model and the accuracy of it was
like is around 70 percent or mobile nets
which is the one that I was using when I
was classifying on my phone you can see
it's a pretty cheap model the accuracy
is about 70 percent but when we start
looking at all the research that's been
done on this and we go all the way over
to the right you know you can see the
the cost of that is orders of magnitude
higher but the actual accuracy isn't
it's going to 80 percent or 82 percent
instead of 70 percent so we said okay
what if we can compare an a network that
learns itself rather than something that
was designed by a humans
do this and this is what we got so when
we started training on small models as
you can see on the left we actually
knock things like mobile net and
inception out of the water so for the
same cost we had far more accurate
models and then when we go over onto the
right we're in the same ballpark if not
slightly better you know so four really
really large data sets and really really
so instead of a thousand images maybe a
hundred thousand images it's able to
classify we've been able to find that
you know we're in the same ballpark
by having these networks instead of a
human designing this network and testing
this network and figuring it out that
the human gives us the base that we're
going to start from but then it learns
and it approves itself over time and if
you remember the alphago and that beat
Lisa doll the champion but then there
was another version of alphago which
learned by itself that beat the one that
beat Lisa doll is the same kind of
technology that was in use there so just
going back to it some of the impact you
can have and we've been working on it
and learned to learn as well for the
diabetic retinopathy as well again you
know comparing with humans taking like
humans and the data that humans have
been able to give us to train a model
but then using learn to learn to improve
on that model well that's where we've
been getting the results in diabetic
retinopathy that are actually improving
on the top over what the top
ophthalmologists can do and again I just
want to reiterate this is not a
replacement for ophthalmologists the
goal here is that if an ophthalmologist
can manually do this and see five people
a day but if they have a tool like this
that allows them to see a hundred people
a day
everybody wins so with that in mind just
remember like you know the whole goal
and the whole revolution of machine
learning is you think about you put your
answers in you put your data in and you
get your rules out and as a programmer
if you're switching that pivot from what
you've done it opens up these massive
massive new scenarios for you that you
can provide value for yourself for your
business and for the world at large so
that's our goal what tends to flow and
that's what we've been working on in the
last year our goal ultimately is to make
machines intelligence and to improve
people's lives
[Music]